rémi richard est installé depuis à peine
un an dans cette exploitation à veauche
ou un village de la haute saône il a
rejoint ses parents il élève des vaches
à lait produit des céréales et en ce
moment avec la sécheresse qui dure pas
facile de s'en sortir
la réunion de lundi en préfecture il
l'attendait comme ses autres confrères
du département à la permis de débloquer
des premières aides comme un dégrèvement
de 40 % de la taxe sur le foncier non
bâti un peu d'impôts en moins à payer
qui retourne dans la trésorerie de
l'exploitation pour rémy c'est mention
peut mieux faire donc en moyenne sur les
exploitations du département cette ces
dégrèvements se représente environ 700
euros par exploitation
donc après c'est une goutte d'eau alors
d'autres aides sont envisagées le
conseil départemental de haute saône qui
par l'intermédiaire d'une mesure
sécheresse pourrait débloquer une
enveloppe de 600 mille euros avec aucune
pluie annoncées dans les dix prochains
jours et des gelées matinales qui
commence à s'installer
les agriculteurs aimerait que cette
situation critique soit mieux prise en
compte au sommet de l'état dans les
autres pays et notamment l'allemagne
puisque on nous compare souvent à
l'allemagne c'est que la chancelière
vient de débloquer à débloquer et déjà
il ya pratiquement un mois
340 millions d'euros possède
agriculteurs donc on aimerait quand même
que le président de la république
considère qu'on est aussi cette que
l'allemagne puisse quelques ce qui est
le cas mais on voudrait quand même bien
que ça arrive assez vite en cette fin
d'année se profile déjà 2019 avec une
grosse inquiétude concernant les colzas
qui ne pousse pas par manque d'eau et
les blés qui devrait commencer à être
plantés dans les prochains jours sans
pluie
même constat ça va être compliqué